many parts of europe are facing a surge
in new coronavirus infections and
hospitalizations
governments are pushing unvaccinated
people to get their shots as soon as
possible but vaccination rates across
the continent still vary greatly let's
take a look leading the pack is portugal
which has 88
of its population fully vaccinated
spain's also doing well at 80 percent
but as you can see in germany just 69
percent of the population is fully
vaccinated
relatively low rate compared with the
rest of western europe now much of
eastern europe is also lagging behind
with countries such as croatia slovakia
and romania having vaccinated less than
50 percent of their populations but the
lowest vaccination rate in the eu is in
bulgaria at just over 26 percent dw's
funny fachar traveled to bulgaria to
find out what is keeping the vaccination
rate there so low
many vaccination skeptics end up here
fighting to breathe in hospital
three doctors are caring for about 40
coveted 19 patients
at this clinic in the town of razza
only half of the medical staff are
vaccinated
that means that only a few can work on
the coveted ward
peter karemchief who is in charge of the
hospital tries to explain what he
himself struggles to understand
maybe it's connected to historical and
behavioral nuances of bulgarians
bulgarians find it hard
i think we need a better campaign to
educate people
spearheaded by politicians
skepticism and conflicting messages from
doctors trickle through to ordinary
citizens in this rural city in the
poorest region of the country
the vaccination rate here is 30 percent
that's considered high here the national
average right now is at about 25 percent
i am worried it's not sufficiently
tested it's still in process
i've seen videos that say that people
who get vaccinated
get some kind of a chip inserted
false information like this is annoying
to those who got vaccinated
i don't get it
so many people have died
why don't they take matters into their
own hands and get vaccinated
this vaccination van is at a supermarket
where sales attract customers but hardly
anyone is willing to receive their first
jab
the medical team inside is frustrated
we don't feel valued because despite all
the work we're putting in people refuse
to get vaccinated for some reason
vaccination teams are understaffed too
hundreds of doctors and nurses have left
for better pay in western europe
the government in bulgaria's capital
sofia has been unable to convince people
about the safety and efficacy of
coronavirus vaccines
the country remains the least vaccinated
nation in the eu
christian gonov used to believe in
vaccine conspiracy theories and shared
false information about them on social
media
i was totally reckless
i'm ashamed of myself for this behavior
he got vaccinated when his father got
infected with covet 19.
thanks to the past two years now i can
see how foolish i looked in other
people's eyes now i think people who
still believe in this are foolish just
like i was
gonna have changed his mind but few
others have and for those continuing the
fight to convince people to get
vaccinated
it's increasingly hard to stay motivated
across the united kingdom people have
been lining up at vaccine centers after
the government opened up booster shots
to anyone 18 years and over prime
minister boris johnson wants all adults
to get a third jab before the new year
as the omicron variant surges cases
there are doubling every two to three
days and the government says omicron
could become the dominant variant within
days
rolling up their sleeves for a third
time
thousands of people in the uk lined up
for their booster shots after prime
minister boris johnson told the country
they were facing an omicron emergency
we can see omicron spiking now in in
london and some other parts of the
country in here in the capital it
probably represents about 40 percent of
the cases by tomorrow it will be the
majority of the cases and it's
increasing
time and sadly yes omicron is producing
hospitalizations and
sadly at least one patient has now
been confirmed to have died
with omicron to combat what he called a
tidal wave in cases the prime minister
announced a booster blitz promising that
everyone aged 18 and up could get a
third vaccine dose before the new year
it's part of a range of measures to
combat a surge in the more transmissible
omicron variant people must now wear
masks in most public places and work
from home when possible as part of the
government's so-called plan b
in france too the government has
announced measures in anticipation of an
omicron fueled sixth wave of covert
the first closures in months came into
force this weekend with the nightclubs
shuttered until at least january
in austria the mood is much more festive
after a three-week nationwide lockdown
shops and cultural venues like theaters
and museums have reopened
though the unvaccinated will still have
to stay home
covered cases here have plummeted paving
the way to a brighter christmas
but with the omicron variant spreading
rapidly around the world there is still
much uncertainty about what the future
holds